独家报道带您看到台股频频创下历史新高
占上两万六千点大关
在高档震荡
散户投资人该不该先获利落袋
台股传奇交易者巨人杰认为
不要因为大盘未接停力
只要趋势不变就续报
他坦言现在改做长线波段
资金比较达九成比重
并持续看好今年最大的主流
仍然是上游的CCLPCB族群
以及国防产业
台股傳奇交易者巨人傑分享了台股資金流動的趨勢
原本被市场称作当冲网的他
考量到短线为纳量不足的问题
近几年9成的比重都放在长线波段布局上
从产业面切入寻找强势族群
以及衍生出的供应链题材
拼的是获利率
我自己看一个族群的强势一定是用涨幅来看
那跟市场的热度来看像我们举个例子前阵子的因为在炒AI的server規格的提升所以前陣子一開始炒的是波線部現在AI Server規格持續的升級
像下一代的AI Server
可能會使用M9等級的CCL
那這部分的話
是我們還會持續看好的
持續看好今年最大的主流
仍然是比較上游的CCL
PCB族群以及國防產業
不過台股頻頻創下歷史新高
占上了26000点大关高档震荡
台地铁也突破了1300元新天价
是否要居高思维先落袋
据人杰认为还是要看当初进场的理由
如果你是一个看比较长期的投资人
那这部分应该是不急着去挺立
因为它是一个产业的趋势
那或是我们现在以光通来讲好了
光通现在从过去的800G的
现在提升到1.6T
那这件事情也还没实现
或是你本来就只是因为技术分析
或是单纯只去追抢的话
那相对来说
现在应该是一个
蛮好的获利了结的时机
不因为大盘未接停力
巨人节改做长线波段
主要以目标价为进出场依据
只要趋势不变就续报
可以做到3.5年
持续在谷海中寻找下一支成长股
记者110 林秋强
台北台方八道